nmda receptors are ionotropic
glutametergic receptors they are found
in the glutametergic neuron it's a
ligand-gated iron Channel and they
regulate synaptic strength and
plasticity
here is the zoomed in view of post
synapse here there could be ampa
receptors which are also ligandrated
iron channels the bind to glutamate and
allows cationic influx unlike
ampereceptors nmd receptor has a
magnesium block so even if the glutamate
is binding to the nmda receptor it might
not allow the cations to get in
after some point when the membrane is
enough positive then the Magnesium block
is removed and then nmd receptor allows
the conduction this can be visualized in
an IV plot where we can see in the
negative voltage there are hardly any
current when the voltage becomes
positive there is current an MD receptor
is strongly implicated in learning and
memory